dude the coolest thing Adam Sandler ever
did does caught on video was when he
brought his daughter to like IHOP or
something and then uh they were like oh
how long is the wait and the girl was
like oh there's no tables we can't see
you and he goes okay we'll go somewhere
else it's just so nice just one day
later that IHOP was shut down close it
that's really sick and then yeah he had
a hit man kill the guy
[Music]
yeah
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we are finally
introducing
Xavier nope
welcome bro
so I called your brother
brought them on so the people who you
are what's up everybody brought a z
um from Gilbert's good friend
introducing me to the team today and I'm
still to be here but yeah just the
content creator
um sketch comic type guy check me out on
oh can I shout my no you cannot
um
tell them to handle dude it's the best
handle in the game how's this guy what
does that mean you popped up in my feed
I think you know what's funny is like I
think Instagram knows like where you at
right so when I'm in Hawaii I get so
much Hawaii content and then your your
uh cop character popped up fake mustache
yeah wait that's you yeah
almost looks like that but like the Reno
9-1-1 dude senior [__] for so long yeah
but the Hawaiian version what the heck I
got the leopard the cheetah shorts
that's the uniform though it says that
Reno Reno 911 oh
I don't know if I'm supposed to say that
but the funny thing is
um yeah I didn't know like but I think
someone reposted your [__] I don't think
it was your channel I think okay yeah I
think like someone rip your stuff I was
like this is [__] funny and then you
know like you know kante Triple H news
fast forward and then like Nick or
someone was like oh this guy's coming
through and I'm looking at your
Instagram I'm all I see this guy yeah
me and my wife we love watching your uh
your the ones you do with your dad where
you're gonna bring your pops just had
him on my podcast and brought off he's
hilarious when he's showing his UFC
moves
yes yes yes you got some hands you know
what we should have done with the at we
had a whole Hawaii episode remember with
our buddy uh Christian so Christian
I think or something like that you know
no I wish Frugal aesthetic yeah okay
maybe but he ain't even like brought a
brother there's like your parents
telling you about a YouTube channel
they're watching oh you guys are on
YouTube right so I watch this YouTube
channel it's like I've never [__]
heard of him show me I don't know who it
is but we had we had him be our official
Hawaii culture guide but then I feel
like on the levels of hawaii-ness you
know Xavier here is probably like you
know because we had we were joking
talking about the levels of halleyism
and then he was like nah he's like I'm
local he's like I'm not even like Hawaii
Hawaii what is he like above
he's like he's like military grown up
Hawaii but then he's mixed okay so then
I think he's like in the middle you know
he's not like total Holly level but like
but he's also not he's local boy but not
like local boy you know what I mean yeah
he's not like West Side local boy got
you yeah yeah yeah I mean just so born
and raised Hawaiian yeah but but not
like as
um
culturally sound as like
you know then I would say the next level
up those are the brothers like in the
Lower East like Carlo making POI oh yeah
you know what I mean that kind I eat the
food yeah you eat it I'll eat the food
you don't yeah yeah I get you I get you
so where's like a white guy who's like
retiring there and go in that Prince
Yorkie Prince Princeville yeah yeah no
Pierce Brosnan lives there yeah oh yeah
James Bond was there really yeah I don't
know I saw him on the beach I was like I
had to double day see is it Nordstrom
yes is it so I I fell on this weird like
one day people were telling me like
there's this whole [__] cult in North
Shore Kauai oh yes love has one it's a
cult and then they've been there since
like the 60s or some [__] or 50s but
they just had like this naked cult and
like or or was that right there maybe
maybe I don't know when they were
established and stuff like that but yeah
they're out there Joe's the guy who's
doing a radio show and like he talked to
his his pre guy for like four minutes
what is it give me the quick hits on the
screen Okay Google yeah whatever I got
it don't worry about it
I'll just say we should do an official
ask a Hawaii local sexual fantasies
it was different from the other one yeah
you met those people though you met the
cult you met the sex guy they got right
they got run out like guys went and
busted they found out what house they
were in because they were live streaming
24 7. the address
then they went busted up their car
um set their car on fire and then they
ended up leaving but super heavy because
what is her name mother
she was like mother God or whatever the
leader of the cult
she was doing all kinds of sexual stuff
you want to talk fantasies she was doing
it with all of them why is there always
a lot of sex but she was old old and
some of the members were young but she
ended up um I think she ended up
committing suicide or she was found yeah
she's passed on so
that's there's always some kind of sex
stuff going on but what you brings
Hawaii brings some interesting people
really she passed on to a different cult
yeah yeah just in the afterlife you grew
up in Kauai
oh yeah Pierce brosn lives on Kauai
bro I was on the beach and a guy pulled
up in a moped with a white shirt just
opened like wind blowing wow I do I do a
double take like holy [__] this is James
Bond who was it yeah he just goes all
the locals did he say
yeah does he sing it yeah
I would sing that [__]
but you're right it was it was Mamma Mia
Pierce Brosnan it was that version yeah
it was mama meal not Missed Out Fire no
not Missed Out Fire Pierce brosn driving
around with [__] Bluetooth speakers
playing the monting on the James Bond
theme is hilarious how do you guys know
each other
we just met through tigerbelly yeah yeah
and then like well how did he get on
tigerbelly
your kalila's friend connected with
kalila and then Ron just random we'll be
honest we were trying to get Max
Holloway he's president Max Hollywood
yeah yeah I lived with Max for for a bit
he's the man crazy big fan but I thought
Max was from the west side yeah if you
didn't have a chick do you think that
you you'd probably be RAM on Carlisle a
little bit right now
it is Hawaii fantasies day I never heard
the most single trick that you know
right now probably the most single trick
that you know um starting with the K oh
yeah kalila oh okay yeah so like yeah
so are you just you just Claus friend
though
cool yeah yeah that's awesome she's been
she's been super chill that's she's
actually super
cool to talk to for like um she wants me
to do stand-up and stuff like that but
are you thinking about doing it I mean
no not really really why not
um
doesn't like interest you that much
it's just it's way different I don't
know if I'm gonna put the time that I
would need to to be good at it do you
feel like more like a comedic actor
rather than a stand-up comedian
I mean I I enjoy doing like the sketch
comment I enjoy like characters wigs you
know the fake sheriff and stuff like
that so
yeah I don't know I think just to do
stand up it just takes a little bit more
um a lot more time and energy yeah
honestly and I don't know if I'm gonna
do you think you have to like sell out
to be a stand-up sell out it's a trap
sell out theaters
well I mean I'm I'm doing gigs where I
do like 30 minute bit pieces but bro
this dude it's opened up like for poly
[__] show yeah no way yeah it was so
weird what Inquirer experience you had
really wait was the room packed was he
mad at you kind of kind of the guy he
was kind of mad he was mad at his his
manager for sure
bro bro he was just mean for no reason
and I'm like why why you gotta chip on
your shoulder we like why can't you be a
normal [__] human being that's that's
I'm like dude no one here cares like
about who's who and he was hell insecure
was he insecure with you all right
because he was like yeah that's why I'm
like I don't know what I can say but
I felt so bad we'll do it for you I felt
so bad because a tour freaking manager
kind of mixed up so it was supposed to
be an opening act um live music for like
10 or 15 minutes then me then Paulie for
whatever reason it's switched so you're
the headliner play so so I'm I'm I'm I
go up in the front so I open up with
some jokes and the crowd is today's
video is brought to you by honey love
you know what a big thing I learned
about women's clothing and just clothing
in general a big big difference is
basically how it fits and how it
complements the body for me it's just
fabric right it just looks cool when I
see a t-shirt I'm like that's cool I put
the t-shirt on because I like the
T-shirt but I didn't really realize what
the difference was you know if your body
is shaped a certain way the clothes
might not complement how you fit after
learning about honey love with the lady
shapewear it really helps accentuate
what they got and that's why I was like
you know what I'm gonna go get something
for my lady I'm gonna get something not
only comfortable and cool but a little
bit sexy because they have a whole range
of stuff they got super power shorts
they got body suits they got all these
things that I'm just like wow how did
you get into that is a huge difference
maybe those things that didn't fit you
before you put it on you're just like oh
what it fits me now because you buy some
of that bootleg [__] you just look like
a sausage that you got stuffed into so
we got a special deal for our viewers
right now get 20 off your entire order
with the code OTR when you go to
honeylove.com the super power short is
helping ladies everywhere scope and
smooth from stomach to thigh by offering
just the perfect amount of compression
so guys get this for your ladies this
piece is also a booty lifter and a
confidence booster the Boost bands on
the back of the thigh gives your bottom
an amazing shape they also got body
suits with 360 degrees of bonded
compression that Smooths your tummy and
your hips and it got built-in bust
support that lifts without underwire so
you know that's comfy shapewear that's
comfortable treat yourself to the best
shapewear on the market by Saving 20 off
honeylove.com with the code
OTR use code OCR
honeylove.com login after
the guy goes on the singer
um the manager's like right great job
you killed it I want to introduce you to
Paulie I'm like whatever cool let's go
we go bro Paulie's losing it in the side
room he's like what the [__] is this guy
on on there like he's just saying like
an acoustic loot you know he's like this
guy just freaking told some jokes got
the crowd laughing and you mean what is
this okay somewhere over the rainbow and
a uke
who's this [__] joke yeah he was he
was not happy I was like and at first I
thought he was joking because I never
met him I never seen his stuff ever
um and then so I was kind of just like
playing along and then
he looks at me and said what do you have
some more jokes so you can go up and I
was like oh this guy is like for real
pissed right now yeah so I had to go
back on what to warm up the crowd guy
yeah
yeah so so that's all when I'm like when
I'm like I don't know if I want to do
stand up I'm like wow let's just play
some funny YouTube videos
well at least at least because you did a
Paulie Shore video we know you didn't
sell out because we know the room was
partially empty yeah
said that joke of the Oscars about like
how key and Brandon Frazier from Encino
Man have Oscars and kind of like yeah
what's Polly doing oh honestly
I'm surprised he's still alive after
that because having met him like to do
the fragility that dude is like [__]
tissue paper I feel like
[__] hey
I don't know what's going on you know
because it apparently hasn't progressed
in four years I feel like
there's probably something going on in
in that world
that doesn't like Hollywood stand up
whatever because his mom's big time
right but then also it's like did he get
treated a certain way because of The
Prestige of the mom because she was the
comedy story comedy store owner and then
everyone loved her right but then it's
like all this stuff right and then so
like
does he come into you like this is what
I my take was when he came into our
space YouTube and all that I felt I saw
a guy that was scared and embarrassed to
be on a show where he felt like the
audience wouldn't know who the [__] he
was because he was asking me this is
YouTube your audience is not even going
to know me I'm like how do you know that
most of my audience are like they grew
up watching your [__] yeah and I had to
give them a motivation and we were go we
were going with it we're like that's
cool like first of all why did you show
up if you think this but then like
second of all
we do this all
the [__] any and then but I think I
think where I where I was like after all
that and I was like he still
disrespected us that's why I don't give
up when he disrespected yeah I'll just
he disrespected Bart he did how
immediately immediately what did he say
to BART BART was just doing some light
Bart was joking we're just having a good
time he comes in and like Paulie's being
weird and then Bart just does a bit real
quick like the lightest bit it's almost
like it's almost like um you know just
something that you say like when you're
just trying to like reach somebody real
quick it was nothing like like I don't
even remember what the joke was do you
but it was like nothing right and then
Paulie like shut Bart down immediately
and I was like okay [__] this guy
actually like I always want to have the
rooms back so I'm like all right [__]
this guy he's against the room it was
the way he did it it was just so
condescending and mean and I was like
bro I sat here stroking your [__] ego
trying to make you feel better because
you're insecure that was after no before
that no no no you did that too but even
after he did that we were still oh we
were still trying to support him yeah be
a good improv team right after that I
was like bro and he didn't even stay the
whole time he said he was gonna stay he
was just like [__] this I'm only doing
two more videos and I'm out like oh
thank you for blessing us with your
[__] presence dude yeah so that's
what was like did these videos actually
go up yeah it's up a couple of them but
we didn't upload it we didn't not all of
them it was the energy was bad dude it
was so bad because it was like you were
just trying to shoot the [__] energy was
weird or weird and he was just like here
on a corner like this I feel like you're
on eggshells he was like that he's just
waiting
he was one of those people he was just
waiting to talk and they're not giving
you anything
yeah sorry you're gonna go up more on
more tours with him or yeah are you like
getting open for him
never at all yeah never actually I don't
even think I got paid yet
and it wasn't even about that but I
don't think I got it yeah and it wasn't
much but I'm pretty sure
so yeah so I can just clean break and
just be like eh right on bro yeah for
sure when did you start doing um your
skits and stuff on long time ago I was
it out so I was working as a custodian
like eight years ago and I just was kind
of always like the class clown guy
whatever and then started on Vine
yeah yeah
damn them guys you know what you heard
of him yeah
just started on Vine and then that got
shut down went to ig and just been doing
it probably for like six seven years now
cool
how long have you had stickers on your
hats for that you like just leave on
your hat
stop it
you know what I'm talking about Oh I
thought you meant I had the tape I
thought I was I was almost like I'm in
but look what you did Ryan
I gave him PTSD because the [__] I've
been staring at the whole time oh you
guys all took your guys off
some people some people like to leave it
on I never had the Snapback official
well that a sticker couldn't stick to
that hat
but but yeah
two dollars baby [__] no
at Daiso but you can't prove it there's
no stickers
there's diesels on Oahu it's like um
yeah it's like a little Japanese
stationery so good man
yeah Diesel's type dude it's like Don
Quixote but really small oh yeah hey
where you wanted to go
ah it's okay say your say your dream go
for it [__] go for it we'll tear it
down I promise yeah yeah I mean
end goal would be to like start doing
some some maybe movies or something like
that like Adam Sandler That's my boy
type oh cool yeah like I just love it I
love Yeah writing or acting
I I love that I like being in front of
the camera
um but just the way that his stuff is
every character you're like holy [__] he
found the guy yeah he found the guy to
fit this role you know I like that I
like that in his in the way that he he
does his movies it's like reoccurring
people I like the team kind of aspect of
that the family yeah and just like
having that guy pop up again in his
movie as maybe one different or the same
guy yeah you know like oh [__] is that
the guy from you in his actual friends
too yeah he's like oh wait it is because
he's saying this is the same mind hey
Rob Schneider again yeah seriously or
the Grandma's Boy dude yeah he's a limo
driver and wedding singers
exactly so it's kind of to like create
something like that would be cool for me
yeah yeah family the second worst guest
we've ever had
[Applause]
YouTube for me when I was uh when I was
uh waiting tables in Pasadena him Kevin
James uh Rob Schneider Rob Schneider was
a regular at a restaurant he would they
brought him over and then at the end I
think like basically their meal was like
60 bucks they tipped like over 200 and
then they went up to every worker and
said bye oh wow yeah and then did they
go up to Rob Schneider and say bye
because you made it sound like you
worked there
I was like [__] waiting tables
he would frequent our establishments
but nah I was just like that's just
[__] cool like
I mean super cool yeah like to say hi to
every single person and then make your
exit you know you didn't even eat that
much you just out here dude the coolest
thing Adam Sandler ever did does caught
on video was when he brought his
daughter to like an IHOP or something
and then uh they were like oh how long
is the wait and the girl was like oh
there's no tables we can't see you and
he goes okay we'll go somewhere else
that's just so nice
one day later that I have to shut down
yeah yeah yeah I close it they didn't
they he didn't pull a card or anything
it's like to teach your daughter that
like we're not those people yeah yeah
that's so sick Superman that's really
sick and then yeah he had a Hitman kill
the guy
the hostess is dead the next day as
close as a skeleton oh yeah it's weird a
sniper just took him out we'll be open
tomorrow we think
well thank you for introducing yourself
to us yeah no thank you I can't believe
you're the freaking cop how do they find
how do they find you how's everybody
find you how's this guy on Instagram
h-o-w-s-d-i-s what does that mean GUI
it's just kind of a thing in Hawaii
where I host a lot of events sometimes I
say some things
that you know maybe kind of
teeter-totter on the line and guys are
like holy [__] how's this guy and then
I chose the house you're like I'm
keeping the sticker on my hat they're
like whoa yeah how's this guy in your
mind you're like yeah yeah I got it I
like to think I'm pretty damn normal
it's just the rest of the world is
living in a delusional space that's true
too and they're less horny than you very
less horny very less horny I'm actually
not that much I just think I'm pretty
normal but everyone else is suppressed
so thank you very much welcome to my
tech talk and buy your Tech talk
[Laughter]
welcome to my Tick Tock welcome to
welcome my tick tocks great
foreign